so you're sitting there all by yourself
and the next table you notice there's
freeman dyson
there's armon burrell
and they're having their own lunch very
nicely and quietly but then they start
arguing and burrell says look give me a
prime dyson says 2 to the 31 minus 1.
omar says now i want the actual digits
don't don't give me any exponents i want
to actually write down the prime so
freeman dyson says all right here's a
prime 111 11111119
times 19 ones there's a prime for you
and burrell says and
getting there but i need at least 20
digits and they can't be all ones and
they think for a minute and there's some
a bit of silence
and you
cough quietly and you say gentlemen i
think i can help you
here's a prime for you twenty digits one
two three four five six seven eight nine
ten nine eight seven six five four three
two one
that decimal number is a prime gentleman
um burrell
closes his eyes and thinks for a minute
says
could be looks like you're right
and freeman dyson says well
congratulations young man
do you know any other primes like that
and you say well
you can look general more generally
at what you get if you go
out up to n so let's write down the
decimal number 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
10 11 12
go all the way up to n and we're going
to string all these digits together and
then we go down n minus 1
n minus 2 down to 4 3 2 1. so that's a
number rather large number if n is large
and it depends on n can i ask a quick
question
obviously
11 counts as one one and 12 counts as
one exactly and when we go back down the
slide will 12 become two one for the now
12 becomes it stays at one two so so we
read the numbers just as they are on the
blackboard and um
they go up and then they go down
so so it goes at the the last would be
eleven ten
nine eight seven six five four three two
one stop and so
you can say when is that a prime for
what n for what n is that a prime well
10 works n equals 10 gives a prime and
burrell says and what's the next prime
you say you have to go out to n equals
2 4 4 6 to get another prime and b and
beyond that we don't know
so this is a pretty large prime and we
don't know anymore
so brady it's a story you can tell at
parties
[Music]
and of course we would like another few
terms so we could the sequence is not
yet the sequence 10
2 4 4 6 is not yet
in the oais because we only have two
terms it's too short how many terms does
it have to have before you put it in the
online encyclopedia there are some
sequences where one term is enough that
are really really important but but for
something like this
um
more than six digits if you can i mean a
couple more terms would be perfect
officially five terms but we'll
certainly make exceptions if the terms
are big neil that prime that has n
equals two four four six must be a huge
number it's a huge number should we
believe there are an infinite number of
ends this will work yes yes absolutely
you can do the do the math you can look
at the probability that within a number
like this is a prime and it's
as
the probability is is one over whatever
it is and it dive that summation
diverges so we expect with confidence
that there'll be infinitely many it gets
harder as the numbers get bigger and
and presumably the man who found 2446
took it some distance further but
i don't think anyone has seriously
looked into this i call this one a
memorable prime the one with 10 in the
middle i'm not finished i have another
segment this is the most wanted prime in
the world so you saw
this primes we just did that you start
at one and you go one two up to n and
then you go down n minus one down to one
but
surely the more logical question is what
if you start at one and go up to n and
stop
so let's do it one that's not a prime
one two that's not certainly not a prime
one two three well it's not a prime it's
it's three times forty one one two three
four obviously if it end if n we're
gonna go up to n and stop and if n is
even there's not a chance if n is five
there's no chance that it's a prime and
if the sum of the digits is three
there's no chance it's a prime
six that's most definitely not a prime
what about one two three four five six
seven that looks like it might be a
prime well it's not it's divisible by
127
sorry so we keep going we want a prime
we definitely want a prime this really
is you know it's sort of the most
natural prime for anyone with 10 fingers
10 11
11 doesn't work either 12 13.
so
let me talk about 13 for a minute so go
one two three four five six seven eight
one
one one one one two one three these are
just the digits of this number okay and
we say all right now that really looks
like it's a prime it's not it's
divisible by
one one three sorry well all right so
you keep going
up to n and every time you get to n you
stop and think
and when n gets large you have to think
quite a while before you can tell
whether it's a prime or not so
various people help me with this and
then i asked the people who run the [ __ ]
the great inter internet and the send
prime search who've been looking for
miss n primes
because this is exactly their kind of
problem and they took it up there a
group of them worked on it for quite a
while and they got up to n equal to 340
000
and they still hadn't found a prime
and i'm afraid they've given up because
do the math look at the chance that a
number like this up to n is a prime
it roughly it looks like there's a
50 50 chance by the time you get up to a
million you should have hit a prime
so i would like to encourage the world
to keep going and find find this missing
prime
this episode has been brought to you by
climb works
we're all pretty conscious of the amount
of carbon dioxide being put into the
atmosphere
climb works is an innovative company
doing something about it by literally
capturing co2 from the air itself
it's then reused by other businesses or
permanently stored underground basically
as mineralized stone here's some of
their kit in action it's in iceland
and you can be a part of it they have
various plans where you pay monthly to
have carbon dioxide captured in your
name
you will know exactly how much co2 was
removed from the atmosphere directly
because of you or if not you this could
be a great present to give that person
in your life who
doesn't want another pair of socks or
endless boxes of chocolates but they
would like to know that they're part of
a planet-saving mission anyway to find
out more go to gift.climbworks.com
numberphile the website's actually
really good for showing how it all works
there's the link on the screen and of
course there will be a link in the video
description our thanks to climb works
[Music]